loustallot nardi journaliste indépendant
bonsoir bonsoir le stade de nardi merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes donc à sao
paulo
on vient de le voir mais effectivement
toujours plus simple d'avoir quelqu'un
sur le terrain pour nous évoquer cette
situation comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui sur place dans une ville
comme são paulo et dans le reste du
brésil pense que je peux vous dire c'est
que la situation a évidemment en de plus
en plus inquiétante
le brésil compte désormais plus de 700
cas confirmés du nouveau corps d'un
virus est presque quarante mille décès
nous sommes le deuxième pays le plus
touché un nombre de cas de contamination
juste derrière les états unis et le
système de santé public brésilien qui
était déjà précaire est désormais au
bord de la saturation depuis plusieurs
semaines dont quelques états du nord du
pays en région amazonienne
mais même dans les grandes villes qui
étaient supposés être préparé à ce chaos
sanitaires comme rio de janeiro et ce en
parle où est ben même si le bilan
sanitaire s'alourdit et en europe
énormément il ya une accélération
incomparable femmes nul par an la
plupart des gouverneurs et des maires
des grandes villes ont décidé de
relâcher petit à petit le confinement et
l'ouverture par exemple des services non
essentiels ont été déjà annoncées ici à
san paolo
une ville qui est l'épicentre de la
maladie dans le pays
avec presque 200 mille personnes
contaminées et un dans l'état de sao
paulo par exemple le confinement n'a
jamais été vraiment respecté comme par
un peu partout dans le brésil ici
désormais seulement 50% de la population
reste confinée chez elle
donc un bilan lourd pour résumer malgré
tout un déconfinement le non respect des
règles par la population est évidemment
tout comme dans d'autres pays d'ailleurs
un manque de masques et de tests oui
exactement le test de dépistage est un
vrai souci au brésil et chercheurs du
centre kovy de 19 brésil
disent d'ailleurs les chiffres officiels
pour être jusqu'à 15 fois plus élevé
donc le brésil pourrait compter en verre
est en réalité entre 2 et 3 millions de
personnes contaminées mais ça on saura
jamais ce sont juste des estimations et
la chute de la popularité de bolton de
molson arrow est une des conséquences de
sa gestion de son inaction face à cette
crise sanitaire
au début de la crise à peu près 50% même
résiliant le soutenait contre seulement
30% de la population actuellement et
malgré l'épidémie dé plus en plus de
manifestations sont en train d'avoir
lieu des brésiliens qui en ont marre de
la gestion de gaulle solaro et qui se
lèvent contre le racisme bien sûr mais
surtout pour défendre la démocratie
brésilienne qui selon lui est de plus en
plus en danger de plus en plus menacé
par le gouvernement bolton a rouge est
bon le président au brésilien a reçu
également de nombreuses critiques de la
part des responsables sanitaires
brésiliens qui ont reproché la
disparition du nombre de décès liés au
corps et 19 du site internet officiel du
ministère de la santé
il ya quelques jours c'était vendredi
dernier bon ces chiffres ont réapparu
quelques heures plus tard mais depuis
vendredi les autorités comptabilise plus
que les décès survécu pardon survenus
ces dernières 24 heures
elle n'y ajoute plus les tests rélévé
positif des patients décédés les jours
précédents donc il ya de nombreuses
critiques qui apparaissent et du corps
médical mais aussi de la classe
politique brésilienne est aussi dans la
population
alors il faut dire un autre cette
affaire de chiffres que j'aille
rossonero ne voulait publier il
semblerait que le président brésilien
fasse pression notamment sur les
gouverneurs des régions justement pour
des cons fine et on imagine les
conséquences dramatiques que cela
peut avoir oui exactement ça déjà le
câble et gouverneurs comme celui de san
paolo où de rio de janeiro qui avait
engagé au début de la paix de l'épidémie
un bras de fer contre le président
jacques bolson arrow et qui avait
impliqué des mesures de confinement sont
en train de relâcher et cela est très
inquiétant selon une étude d'ailleurs
publié par l'université de washington le
brésil pourrait compter presque 200
mille morts par le nouveau coronavirus
jusqu'au mois d'août à pouvoir atteindre
jusqu'à 5000 décès par jour
mais selon le responsable de cette
recherche américaine les chiffres
pourraient être encore plus élevé si les
le gouvernement et la population à
brésil et ne prennent pas cette crise au
sérieux et si le look down n'est pas
instauré pendant au moins deux semaines
mais ce scénario semble pas du tout
envisageable
il sera temps de voir exactement le
contraire le confinement est de moins en
moins respectée par la population et les
services non essentiels comme des salles
de sport ou alors des banques ou des
agences immobilières commencent à
rouvrir leurs portes un peu partout dans
le pays ce qui est très contradictoire
parce que la courbe de cas de
contamination et de décès ne cesse de
monter
merci au salon mardi d'avoir été avec
nous avoir exposé cette situation
inquiétante au brésil